well the 90-day challenge is marrying
the end everyone you you guys are
cranking it up now only four days ago
try and try and do we've been a bit busy
here but well I don't expect you to do
it during working hours they expect me
to take more at home don't worry
so how are you guys surprised your goal
goes yeah I'm behind in my listening
right so I'm going to work really hard
this last weekend and writing reading is
still challenging
yeah but but listening you're behind in
your listening because you haven't
reported it because it doesn't
necessarily court on the site I just
like yeah I don't listen enough okay my
advice wear these and if you haven't
said something to you but writing is
difficult you have to look it up because
you don't know the ending or you don't
know how to spell it
this is how to spell yeah okay can I
tell you how I keep because I'm doing
Korean right and the last time I
submitted writing it consisted of two
parts one part was where I copied what
was in the textbook because I was
learning to write the hunger and the
other part I dictate because there's
dictation software on my back so when I
copy from the book I had more mistakes
then when it dictated alright or taking
is e and the thing is the dictation is
about 80% 70% like sometimes it'll be
quite accurate than
get garbage that's strange that you
would have typos yes yeah you know I
should definitely hear your idea stifle
free
typos in Korean is a given because they
have their great humble alphabet that
they're so proud of essentially all can
be one of two sounds what why don't you
symbols the sounds are a that can I have
the same one and yeah they like those
are the only two that are the same but
when you say or not oh no oh oh tell me
there's been all with one of these guys
and one of these sticking out versus the
vertical guy with a little thing one
into all and one okay when you hear them
speech it it's the same and half the
time
even the who sounds like a hole so it's
actually very I find it very difficult
to figure out which of those symbols it
is but my dictation is pretty good at as
long as I said close alright so and this
is a problem in French because you got
all the accents
that's my dictation if you want to for
sure I ain't eëtion is a great way of
doing it you got a macro but yeah but I
should show you but I just I have my
iPad there and I I just think of what I
want to say and I just read it in an
occasion I don't know a word so then I
go to my I have Google Translate as a
dictionary look up the word I come back
I dictate and what I found for Korean
you have today dictate like one word at
a time otherwise it just kind of runs it
all together
oh and Korean you actually they not only
do you form the the symbols collective
form one syllable call it and then that
bunches together with another collection
of symbols to form word then they make a
little space there and in my first
submission I got marked down for her
so yeah writing is what I tell you mark
over there phones me up he says dad you
haven't met your goals you're not gonna
meet your goals
well you haven't listened enough you
have listened enough you haven't learned
enough words and you haven't written
enough and I said well I listened like
and now I don't have to learn today yeah
I just have intercourse it's not see ya
just my my under two hours
no because it's at least yeah that's for
sure yes not the words I just went
through on in the vocabulary section I
sorted them by frequencies and started
out with the most frequent where is the
for asterisk words and I already know
most of this even though I haven't
necessarily worked my way through them
on my flashcards because I have been
explosive so often and I know as I just
went through there until I had six or
seven hundred words that I know mm-hmm I
was down to the one star words by then
fine but the writing and I have been
resisting the writing because if you
gotta learn all these little swing leza
it's hard especially because it's not
like you type phonetically you actually
have to move your mouse on the keyboard
this virtual keyboard on the screen and
you click on this upside down you know
our whatever it might be after a while
your your elbow is sore that the
solution is the iPad the dictation and
even in terms of typing and just have to
touch the screen it's a blast and you
should get yourself a French keyboard do
all your writing on your on your iPad
yeah and but don't type it all I record
it then go back in and correct the
missing is eventually in fresh with the
accents because it automatically puts
them in that's the one thing I did
figure out even when typing French when
I was writing in French that the best
thing to do is to write without the
accent then you have to get the French
keyboard and remember which key is which
it just yeah it takes too long just
write a note and then do the spellcheck
and it finds all hacks
were you right most of them when you
miss a few so on one of them one of the
many annoying things YouTube the most
everybody there's a wall there's a long
list what I'm most annoying is they
automatically put some stuff into spam
so every time I go to answer there's
like four or five items there that have
been for some reason put into called
spam nothing spammy about them at all
right I think oh my name so I got people
who commented three months ago on some
video that I did however long ago right
and I don't I'm not aware and when I go
in and see I'm looking I got one met
that you know comment there that's live
and then I see I got a bunch of stuff in
spam and I see that there's messages
there that are three months old the glue
at least the Google decided were spent
for some rules another thing that really
annoyed me somebody came out and said we
should on link we should you know once
you make a word then any word that's
related to that word should be
considered no that's the point of view
I'm gonna don't necessarily agree and I
said well yeah you know it's it's
helpful to provide and we may in fact do
that and to provide some connection to
similar you know related words but it's
not obvious and I so then I go say
Thursday well you know people may not
say they saved a word a day to go right
are they then when they see the word
vote like evil I couldn't write the word
vote because Google kept on converting
it into font I would go v Ont try to
move on font and I had to go back and I
don't know that I think Reese's your
mock is that my Mac yeah so in the end I
have to go with an arrow like once
everything have to move with an arrow
you know cuz I was plenty out you know
yeah baby they go home they I you all
there's so many don'ts no it's not I'm
autocorrect
what I can't figure out is autocorrect
on the Mac sometimes activates and
sometimes doesn't what determines which
program it's activated I haven't figured
out sometimes its work and work
sometimes it doesn't just be nice to be
consistent yeah but it is annoying when
it corrects words that are but it's the
same one year when you that's going are
dividers
you've turned it off and on your device
to everything because of stuff that you
catch I think I just got so you don't
easy excuse for you might tell me though
I don't think they're very stupid or an
insult or something right well that
happens a lot like your type something
and then you press like especially when
you're texting someone you have
autocorrect on happens all the time if
people send me messages and they say
like yeah that's me Ted go go oh sorry I
meant you know whatever but totally
unrelated Lee doesn't make any sense but
when you're typing a message you type it
in the you press Enter you don't look
and then however when I look at what I
actually typed before they autocorrect
it I type total garbage
that's the autocorrect is pretty good
well the best thing with autocorrect is
when you're switching into the language
like on YouTube I get people have
commenting in Spanish and other
languages and it'll pick up like it'll
pick up the fact that I'm typing in
Spanish and it will pick up Russian
it'll take up the language that I'm
typing in and corrected for me otherwise
I don't have to go get the keyboard
weird what is this on YouTube when I'm
answering it'll pick up and so I'm just
gonna be the same exact sense what
you're extremely here like even in
Russian you got the little you know
whatever you call that guy you know so
you gotta go find the keyboard and stuff
yeah
anyway we have four days I'm gonna be
working hard the only goal that I'm
behind on now is writing but because I
cheat and I use dictation yeah which is
okay why says cheating all you want to
do is practice sort of without speak you
know but you you say it then you correct
it make sure it's right that's kind of
the idea you want to think about what
you're gonna say stop actually it's a
really go away and make sure it's
correct and try to submit something more
more proper than when you're
its output is actually very very good
I'm gonna you've inspired me now to do
my I still have like 300 words of
Italian to submit for writings I'm gonna
try the dictation month ago and I tell
you getting the I have had three
different people correct my career on
our exchange mm-hmm and I've never done
that much because I've always felt you
know I'm more in than listening
everything yourself but it's a great
feeling
when you get your corrected text back
and someone took the trouble to go
through it and there's some comments
there and then I import it and I study
the words and try to figure out which a
you know Korea and I'll never remember
you know shake shingle which which of
the a is is in or out of it but it's
great
yeah so I'm glad you pushed me and
sometimes you need to be pushed so I'm
pushing you and you hear I can't be the
only one mark well mark cool uphold the
Kaufman tradition there you go okay
anyway
back to the grind now yep back to a
studying Korean what